Speaker 1: I want to talk a little bit about
book banning.
One of the comments that I'm seeing pretty
regularly on the shorts, YouTube shorts that
I post about Republican book banning efforts
is people commenting and saying banning these
books is good because they're only banning
pornographic books and books that aren't age
appropriate.
Let me show you some of the comments that
I've been receiving.
I won't even name the these are just YouTube
people with long strings as their usernames,
but here are some of the comments.
How is banning a porno book on a middle school
library Fascism, isn't it?
At worst, censorship based on age and at best,
parenting and protecting children from losing
their innocence sooner than necessary.
It's not fascism.
If it's inappropriate content for kids, schlock
of God says no, Banning books that are not
appropriate for kids is morally correct.
JP Music says there's a huge difference between
limiting what books schools can have available
for kids and removing books from public libraries
or not allowing the sale of certain books,
JD says.
Have you looked at the content of the books?
Many are pornographic in nature.
Dr. Och says it depends on what books are
being banned.
Planet Positivity says false when it applies
to children.
Extremists on the far left and right want
their propaganda taught to kids and both are
age inappropriate.
Jan says it's critical that parents be able
to make these decisions.
I don't want the government deciding what
my kid can and can't read.
But Billy Beans said restrictions imposed
by parents are equally bad as restrictions
imposed by governments, if not worse.
Jay says banning books is not the same as
removing nine age appropriate books from elementary
school libraries.
So I decided to look at some of the books
that are being banned, and you can easily
find these these lists.
Penn dot org has a list, and here are some
of the books that are regularly banned.
One is called Genderqueer a memoir, and it's
about a person who uses pronouns like air
and explains why to their family.
This one has been banned more than 40 times.
All Boys Aren't Blue by George Johnson, which
is a series of essays from an LGBT activist
that explores his childhood and adolescence.
Out of Darkness by Ashley Hope Perez.
A dangerous, forbidden romance rocks a Texas
oil town in 1937, when segregation was a matter
of life and death.
The Bluest Eye by Toni Morrison.
Because it obsesses, it examines our obsession
with beauty and conformity.
And you can go through these and you can get
a bigger list.
And this is going to be sort of hard to see
because of the zoom.
But you see that there are all these different
books that have been banned.
Some have been banned by administrators.
Some have been challenged by parents.
You see all these different examples.
And I have to tell you, I spent time randomly
picking these books and I went to Amazon and
I did the look inside and I read, you know,
a number of pages that are available.
The vast majority of these books are neither
pornographic nor extreme.
However, many of them do have storylines that
it seems many right wingers don't like.
Sometimes there are gay characters.
That's it.
So they want the book banned.
Sometimes there are descriptions of sexual
encounters and we could have a conversation.
Is that appropriate for seven year olds?
Well, maybe not.
But is it appropriate for high school juniors?
Yeah, it's fine.
In some of them, there are descriptions of
non-binary people, or whatever the case may
be.
The overwhelming majority of these books are
not pornographic and.
It is very clear that a lot of the people
saying it's good to ban these books have absolutely
no idea what is in the books.
I also want to say another thing.
A lot of these books don't seem that great
to me.
And what I mean by it is I'm not saying.
A lot of this stuff is just personal preference
at the end of the day, right?
Like, what kind of stuff do you enjoy reading?
A lot of these books, as I look at them, aren't
particularly titillating, but they also don't
seem particularly interesting to me.
And it seems to me that making a big deal
for any reason out of these books just doesn't
really make sense.
If this is a book that a teacher wants to
have in a curriculum.
It just seems very strange to get all shaken
up about it.
And what I was reminded of, of course, is
that the right wingers that want a lot of
these books banned are really the snowflakes.
They love to say, Oh, the left is so sensitive.
The left can't handle anything and all these
different things.
I mean, listen.
Gay relationships exist.
Slavery existed.
Brutality existed.
Non-binary people exist.
And just saying that the inclusion of that
those as topics is, quote, inappropriate for,
quote, kids, particularly when a lot of them
don't distinguish between a first grader and
a high school junior senior.
They seem to be exposing themselves as the
snowflakes that can't handle.
And if anything and you know, I don't want
to go too far down this path, but if you look
at historical efforts to ban, you know, so-called
degenerate art, as Nazis wanted to do, if
you look at all other efforts that we've seen
over time from authoritarian leaning movements
and leaders to control media and books and
publications, it's really ugly stuff.
And quite frankly, it mostly seems to backfire.
So take a look at the books that they actually
want to ban.
Go on Amazon, click on Look Inside, look,
read a little bit, and you will very quickly
see that this is not actually about banning
porn.